欢迎收听古爱,我是猛公
本期节目由ZZZ Slipper
减二度两感忘忧枕赞助
上次介绍忘忧枕的时候大盘42000
很多人问现在是不是太高
现在47000
大家开始想早知道那时候就多买一点
42000的时候想要等拉回
真的拉回又想再看看
一路看到47000终于决定进场
买完第一件事还是担心是不是买在高点
市场走了5000点
人也跟着绕了一圈
最后共同点还是一样
晚上仍然睡不着
投资人真的是蛮忙的
有部位要顾
没部位也会怕错过
白天看台股晚上看美股手机放下了
脑袋还在算明天到底是要加码还是减码
股票归股票人生还是得休息
不要让颈椎跌破支撑
ZZZ Slipper减二度量感忘油整
是物理治疗师联手设计
有三种高度可以调整加上双弧度切面
不管震睡测睡都可以照自己的睡姿去调
整形用量感清水棉支撑感接近记忆整
但躺起来又多了一点羽绒整的柔软
不会只有硬撑着脖子的感觉
里面还有一层Wing Cool量感沙内整套
主打-2度凉感
平常睡觉容易觉得热
喜欢枕头凉一点的人
这个差异比较有感
枕头当然不会告诉你
明天该买还是卖
42,000会烦
47,000还是会烦
行情什么时候
能够让人家完全放心了
但至少躺下来的时候
脖子可以先不用跟着盘式一起震荡
资讯栏有主委听众专属的优惠
使用手机FB和LINE
登入吉祥无二折
蛮多时候会跟大家聊到说
就当你今天有一个想法
你就要立刻去做尝试
你不要等到说
可能東風俱備所有東西都弄好才開始
因為一般來講你不一定會等到東風
所以其實不管是在我們自己的投資工作裡面
有時候會出現先買再研究
然後再來就是可能在自己加入的一些創業的領域
去投資一些小店或甚至像是硝南資本
其實對我來說都是我對一些東西有熱情
那我可能不一定是瞭解全貌
但就是先把它做下去
最近有一個我覺得蠻北蘭的案例可以跟大家分享
總之就是反正我們校南下
應該會開始往海外去做投資
除了台灣的團隊之外
我們會開始去物色一些歐洲
或者其他亞洲的電玩同修們
找到不錯的
我們可能就願意把資金打進去
最近就有接洽到一個團隊
就說他們會去TGS
所以可以在TGS上面跟我見面
剛好我們的一些partner
之前有幫我安排TGS
然後說在前面的business day
就是專門給企業主
或是一些可能投資方去參加的那幾天就類似說可能電腦展前面幾天是給一些商務人士去的然後說有弄到票要讓我去可是不知道為什麼我心中就一直覺得TGS是什麼台北 Game Show
就是我就一直覺得這個是在台北
所以當我去接觸到外國團隊的時候
我也想說太巧了吧
對方竟然剛好要來台北
那這樣不就是超棒的嗎
我就說那我跟我的
夥伴呢
就是可以在TGS上跟你見面或什麼的
然後最後面真的是突然間靈光乍現
就是一般來講
因為現在的
生活中的事情已經夠多了
所以有蠻多東西
我都是等到可能最後的一兩天
其實從小時候是這樣
就是那種暑假作業都最後一天才寫
那反正時間快到了
然後再趕快準備一下
看是怎麼樣再去
反正就求來就打
不會提早去做太多的擔心
那可是那一天就突然就有靈光乍現
就覺得
那不然現在規劃一下說
TGS到了時候
我到底該怎麼樣去做準備
白天我可能可以做什麼
那晚上可以幹嘛
然後才發現
不對啊
台北GameShow的時間
根本就不是下個禮拜啊
那另外一個TGS時間
剛好在下個禮拜的時候
是嗎 Tokyo GameShow
原來在東京
所以身為一個遊戲資本的創投創始人
我是不知道說原來TGS就是東京電玩展
其實我之前也都沒有去參加什麼電玩的展會
我就是一個非常喜歡打電動
然後在我的Steam的Library裡面
有超級多遊戲的一個玩家
其實我在這之前是沒有去參與說
任何什麼遊戲開發的圈子
或是去認識一些遊戲的創作者之類的
我沒有啦 我最多就是買你的遊戲
然後可以抖內 我就多抖內
所以我是一個非常稱職的消費者
但我都沒有網上去做認識之類的
我根本就不知道說
原來TGS是東京電玩站
所以當我知道這件事的時候
我真的覺得還好
那一天突然間靈感乍線
然後想要先看一下
因為一般來講我都是
最後一刻才動作那一種
甚至我會覺得
我如果太早去準備一些東西
像上幾集跟大家分享說
跟Sony Ventures還有Twitch的創辦人
有去聊了一下
關於遊戲跟新科技的投資
這些東西如果太早準備的話
其實我反而會不知道要講什麼東西
所以我是那種
就是我做事情要在一定的壓力之下
特別是我知道火要燒屁股的時候
我的創作的效率就會非常好
我就可以很快的把事情做完
真的是靈感乍性
還有有去做查詢
不然我真的覺得不知道
如果說我是前一天才發現的話
隔天機票不知道買不買得到
但就提早發現
然後趕快就把機票準備一下
然後才知道說
這次的電玩展是辦在千頁
千頁我想說以前可能看一些
就有一些印象
好像說可能漫畫或是一些動漫的劇情
在千葉之類就這個地方你很常聽到所以你心中想的是千葉應該是一種大城市吧但其實最後面就在我的角度我就覺得說反正就是東京附近就東京超級大的所以像什麼橫濱
在我看來就是好像也是東京的一環
就是整個那種超級大的一個都會圈
就會想像說這邊應該也是蠻好玩
蠻多東西的
但是一查就發現
它那邊感覺跟南港展覽館有一點像
反正就是在台北市相對邊垂一點的地方
現在在南港展覽館那邊就是
開始有一些大型的mall
我就注意到在千葉的展覽館附近
也是有很多大型的mall
可是相對之下在飯店的供應上
至少可能你如果去南港展覽館
你家可以有汗來之類的吧
但在千葉那邊
也是沒有什麼可能不錯的飯店
也不是說我的屁股
一定要好的飯店還可以住
只是那些飯店蠻多
你查起來是很嚇人
想說這什麼東西
要嘛是超級小
要嘛就超級舊
後來問了一些遊戲圈的人士才說
附近都是這樣
特別是那種展場附近的
就是專門去削那些去參展的人
所以東西就可能比較鳥一點
要好一點可能要往前一站去
可是往前一站又會擔心說
如果電玩展真的超級多人的話
你通勤又會比較麻煩一點
所以最後面我就覺得
反正就是找一個在旁邊的飯店
將就一下就好
最終的目的還是希望
這一次蕭南可以順利的找到一些
不錯的海外團隊
然後可以參與
就最近開始去思考這方面的東西
包含
如果說我們真的去投一些在歐洲的團隊
那到底投後管理要怎麼做
不是說我們錢丟出去要自己長大
你總是要看著人家
你總是要大概知道發生什麼事情
即便我們已經算是做出最小程度的干涉
但總是還是要有人去做這件事
所以就在思考說
如果真的不小心走向國計畫的話
那這後面的東西到底該怎麼做
但有時候就覺得說反正水到渠成
真的如果可以退到那一步的話
可能生命就會冒出一些人
就類似說其實本來在做校男的時候
他是一個
又像靈感乍線
就是你想要去挺你自己喜歡的團隊
然後意外的變成是一個公司的規模
然後還越做越大
後來就越來越多拼圖的產生
包含說像一些有志之士
他不一定是你的股東或是參與者
他知道你有這個東西
那就想要介紹一些人
所以像在上個禮拜
也跟一些日本的遊戲大廠的人見面
然後才知道說
就在這些遊戲大廠
他們其實有蠻多的遺珠之憾
就是他有很多團隊他想要投
但是礙於他的規模
然後或是說
礙於公司的一些內控導致
他不可以把這個check發出去
但這些團隊就非常適合我們
因為我們是沒有任何包袱的對我們來講就是遊戲性可能是最重要的然後再來就是團隊的人如果OK的話那我們都可以考慮把支票發出去所以就意外的接軌到一些就是可能人家挑勝人家不要的東西
但那是你要的東西
你覺得他非常有機會
所以在這邊稍微的分享一下
一個很別人的心得
就是身為一個遊戲創投的創本人
但其實也是有蠻多事情的
是搞不清楚邊做邊學
然後非常感謝在路上
一路上都有很多的貴人相助
同時自己也是非常努力
就是不懂的東西該怎麼辦
就一直多研究
然後你也不要怕碰壁
反正碰壁怎麼講
就以前當兵班長講的
理多人不怪嘛
你就是對每個人都是
盡量把自己的姿態放低
反正從頭到尾也不覺得自己
真的是什麼了不起的東西嘛
你就是盡量就多問
那也非常感謝有這麼多的
這些遊戲圈的前輩
或是一些發行商業者
都非常樂意的來指導我們
讓我們可以一路走在
還蠻不錯的路上
所以下一半也回去東京
那希望可以找到一些
有趣好玩的東西
然後再來節目上跟大家分享
這個對我來說也蠻重要
因為現在這個節目已經有點變成說
我會想說
我每一集有沒有什麼東西可以講
如果沒有什麼東西可以講的話
那代表我可能已經停止前進了
大概就這樣的感覺
就你不可以一直講說過去的事情
過去的事情沒什麼好講
重點是現在在發生什麼新的東西
未來有什麼樣新的東西
可能是一個蠻重要的
所以這個日記本也變成是
我的一種去驗證
到底過去一陣子
你有沒有做一些不一樣事情的
很好的一個管道
大概這樣
稍微跟大家分享一下
接下來我們來進入社長的話題
那最近的盤面還是持續的維持震盪
其實已經差不多一個多月左右
是這樣的一個局面
特別它有點像今天剛好有一個朋友講
他說這個是隔日沖的地獄
如果你想要做隔日沖的話
特別是那些鎖得越死的
隔天一般就越慘
這個在台股裡面有非常多的案例
前一天鎖得好好的
但隔天就直接開地
然後大家大逃殺
甚至直接殺到跌艇去
但是可能等個幾天之後
又再一次的復甦回來
所以你只要搶快就被打了
這個就有點類似我們前幾集跟大家講
就是其實這一波行情
它並沒有到特別難做
但如果說你是想要搶快
你是想要用之前的方法
可能3到6月那段時間
盤很好 反正上車就一定會立刻噴
就會有比較多的震盪成本
這個震盪成本可能會擊殺成塔
就是它只有一點點
但是久了之後
加起來可能蠻恐怖的
搞不好吃掉你靜止的5% 10%以上
這都是會發生的
所以這個要盡可能的去避免
就是當你今天遇到這種奇怪的盤勢
要嘛就是你持續堅持
你把它做法 但是把部位給縮小
要嘛就是可能稍微的去調動一下自己的做法
像我就有去稍微調動一下自己的做法
因為已經很明顯的可以去識別說
你越要去追牆就越會被上課
可是最終它其實都是慢慢墊高的
我不如有些東西即便我今天真的超級想買
但我就先等待一下
沒有買到就算了
因為市場上機會這麼多
接著隔個幾天就發現說
它真的就掉下來給你買了
你買了之後後面又有人再把它凍能上去
然後接著可能到某個地方又再次的掉下來
這邊當然也可以選擇去偷吃人家豆腐
就是人家凍能的時候你就反凍能丟給他
只是我自己還是比較不習慣去做太短線的事情
所以你就知道說
OK你們想要鎖個半死
你們明天一定全部都要丟出來
但沒關係
反正我至少是買在相對低位
所以就還算是可以忍受
自己當然也有試著去嘗試去
不然說像有一些快漲停的東西
去把它弄到漲停之類
可是你就知道會不會打
所以規模是持續的在縮小
我還是相信說
這個東西會等到大盤開始新高之後
就會去改善
大盤就是已經在新高附近
可是就是遲遲沒有看到表態突破棒
然後讓大家信心回來
讓大家重建人與人之間的信任
這個還是沒有看到
於是我們就先不用去聚焦太多題材相關的東西
因為當盤好才有題材可以看
現在就比較偏像是一個震盪的盤施
我們就來看一下最近市場上發生什麼有趣的事情
最近Google Cloud在Golman Sachs這邊有辦一場會議
然後派出的是Thomas Kurian
就算是他們在Cloud這邊的一個大頭
他有一些分享
我覺得超級精彩
然後跟自己在過去的一些想法算是有契合在一起
所以大概說一下自己的看法
首先他評論了一下
他整體業務的動能
他提到說他們家新客獲取速度
是一年前的兩倍
然後再來大型交易
也就是說超過1億美元的
Code on Quote跟E on Year
都是兩倍以上的成長
再來如果今天客戶有commit的時候
就要說我要買100美元的東西
可是最終他們幾乎都會花到
大概150美元以上
這什麼意思
就是超額消費是大於50%
這是一個
就在市場上需求很好的一個訊號
目前他們的產品線
每個營收都是超過了10億美元
持續的成長
營收跟營業利益都是持續的變好
市占也是越打越大
其中講出了一個比較嚇人的東西
就是說AI伺服器目前在他們公司來看
整體的回收期是不到兩年
這件事情其實我們在之前
SpaceX跟Tesda反正就是他們的超大型集群
然後換了拿去租給別人
我們就大概已經知道說
其實AI伺服器的回本速度是很快
但他後面補充了一個
就是市場上可能不一定有被充分認知到的事情
他說自研晶片回收期在減半
這什麼意思
就是他自己的ASIC TPU
他們現在已經有在做TPU as a Service或是TPU外銷了這個東西它只需要一年的時間就可以把它收回來這其實是一個超級變態恐怖的事情
所以於是你就可以去了解
當然我們不是說
像Google是Steer away from Gemini
前沿模型都不做
它還是有持續在做
只是前陣子有一個
市場上的算是已經開始慢慢變成共識的東西
就是Google目前的前沿模型好像不太行
然後3.5可能被跳過
要直接往下一代去
是不是他們開始把一些資源去移到他的infra那一塊去
這個其實你從這一次的會議的分享就可以理解
如果你是管理層
如果你看到這樣子的數字
你會不會選擇去把天平稍微往這個方向去做傾斜
當然我們不是講說
Petri家就是不想去搞千元模型
他們一定都還是會搞
他們絕對也不會放棄
他們只是稍微的聚焦多一點在flash那部分
但你可以理解為什麼他們會去做出這樣的一個判斷
因為過往有一個說法是這樣子
就是這些AI infra的投入者
他們可能不一定會賺錢
然後抑或是
就算下的Backlog的數字很好
可是等到反轉之後
他可能會第一個爆炸
但是這一次的分享
我覺得他給大家一個最大的震撼點就是
原來他們賺錢的速度可以這麼快
就是Reaffirm的
之前可能我們從Elon那邊
所得到的一個情報
就是原來他的MegaCoster
拿去租給別人可以回這麼快
就原來他賺錢的速度可以這麼快
所以在這樣的狀況之下
你要怎麼樣去想像說
AI的市場會在短期內爆炸呢
因為他們印鈔的速度實在是太快了
所以前陣子有超級多人在聚焦
在Google的自由現金流轉付
但你現在看到這個
你不覺得他轉付是很正常的事情嗎
他當然要加快去投資
他到底要去哪裡找
可以一年回本
或是他去買那種general purpose的
他也可以兩年回本
你去哪找這種東西
所以你說他的自由現金流轉付
他開始開大capac大花錢
然後跟可能沒有再去做回購
廢話因為他已經告訴你說
這個東西的ROIC是比回購更好
如果說今天開始去跑回購的話
代表說可能在市場上沒有找到其他機會
他才去回購自己的股票
因為回購自己的股票
績效是最好的
現在就是因為他已經找到
這種身材的管道
特別是在這一次由他們
Cloud的一個資深的經理人出來
直接跟大家講這件事情
他其實就象徵者
其實Google前陣子那樣的一個轉型
是蠻好的一個方向
當時我們也是有這樣去猜測
我們唯一覺得潛在的一個downside是怎麼樣
就是你本來是前顏模型的一個聚焦者所以大家可能願意給你一個比較富含想像力的p ratio的乘數因為我們都不知道未來世界會長怎麼樣所以當你今天去把這個前沿模型持續的往前推
即便你不一定會賺錢
可是大家可能給你一個更高的乘數
當你今天已經把自己定義成為
是Infra的Supplier
你就變成是類似水電業者
水電提供者
你相對的你的乘數可能就會低一點
可是你賺進來的錢是非常實際的
那個都是真金白銀持續的灌進來
所以也會去懂得
為什麼巴菲特會去投Google
然後他還強調說
這個決定是要自己做的
因為在這之前
Google可能他投的東西是
就我們講比較科技
比較空中樓閣
你可能要稍微有點想像力
才可以知道
因為沒有人知道未來的事業長怎麼樣
但是你今天回到
這些基礎設施的提供者
這完全就是PokerShot的一個防守領域
我可以直接算出說我投多少錢
我可以換成多少的一個收益
你就可以懂說
為什麼他們會去做這樣的一個投資
特別是在這一份資料的時候
就是更加確定
然後再來就是
他們也提到說
他們有非常好的一個CP值
它的訓練是優於市場2.7倍
推論優於80% CPU30%
ML的模型執行成本是業界最便宜
而且是人家的2.5倍
像這些比較偏向宣傳式的語言
一般我們今天稍微看很久
就有點類似說那些大模型出來
都一定講自己多屌
怎麼樣去虐別人
然後一些硬體推出來
也一定會去強調說
自己跟NVIDIA的Benchmark比起來
那可能好多少
但重點是什麼
重點是我們最近看到
像前陣子最紅的就是Fable
大家就想說好像只剩下
Enthropy的Fable在市場上
有辦法搞出什麼東西
你不要講說Google什麼很鳥
你說OpenAI也是整個不見的
然後再來就是
Enthropy的一些財務出資
大家看得很喜歡覺得說
這個就是一時之選
再來可能就已經沒有人
可以跟他競爭了
結果隔沒有多久
馬上OpenAI端出了Astra
你看一下所有的社群頁面
全部人都在狗吹Astra
所以這真的就有點驗證
我們之前的一個猜想
就是情安模型
大家真的不要太快去概觀認定
很常去講說什麼
誰又被誰擊敗
因為你不到
半摔期已經不是半年了
可能是兩三個月
你就很快就會再打自己臉
就是人家立刻就會再超越
因為畢竟
他們去設計這些全面模型的時候
他們的目標絕對不是說什麼
我要去吃人家煙屁股
在後面去吃剩飯
他們每個東西他要推出來
他一定就要比別人強
所以其實你已經可以知道說
3.5一定就是蠻鳥的
所以他才不推出
他直接推4
4一出來就要蓋別人火鍋
就類似說
Extra出來
然後蓋Fable火鍋
這樣的一個感覺
所以如果說你看了這個環節
你也去挖了背後的財務數字
你會發現索蝦在模型這邊其實那個溢價的權利我覺得是慢慢的在收縮那個API的費用其實都已經出現了一個持續收斂的情形這代表什麼東西
代表說你去使用這些AI模型
他們可能各有各的強處
雖然我們說一樣都把它稱為是大模型
一樣可能都是 commodity
可是可能覺得說在anthropic這邊
在coding這裡還算是
大家有口皆杯都覺得它是最厲害的
所以即便可能像Astra
有很多很酷的表現
但是一些coder
可能還是會選擇去使用anthropic
但是無論你是使用哪一個模型
你可能會開始發現說
你為他付出的某一些特別技能的
Premium的那個數字是持續的在往下壓
所以到最後他真的就慢慢變成是
像一種commodity的感覺
就是大家所付出去
创API的錢可能是持續的熟練
在這樣的狀況之下
Google他提供的Solution
就會變成非常的吸引人
就如果說以前我的商品
就站在大模型商的角度
我的商品因為某些特殊的功能
我可以收取很高的一個Premium
所以我可能也因為這樣子
願意去採購一些
可能是專門for我的usage
所要用到的各種算力或是說硬體
但如果大家的這一塊
所收進來的錢是越來越趨於一致的話
我們講的不是完全一樣的
就是說以趨勢來看
假設開始拉平的話
選擇一個高CP值的硬體
就變成是一個非常有吸引人的事情
然後特別是我們在BlockCon的電話會議裡面
我們是有了解到
Huck現在已經算是
就是All-in這些SEE業者
他也希望他們長大
這些蒙古來的孩子
希望可以好好念書要把他們養大
所以如果今天Amplopic或是說OpenAI
他們在收入開始趨同的一個狀況
我們不是講說總額
就是說API的Token Feet
算起來是越來越像的一個情形
他有可能就會去選擇
這些可能在成本上面
是比較有優勢的一個硬體
當然現在講這個只是用現況來說
我們不知道說可能VR-Ubin丟出來
或是後面的FAMON搞不好
又會有不一樣的光景
可是現階段來看
其實TPU真的算是一個
CP值蛮高的一个选项
所以大家可能就更会往TPU的方向去走
当大家往TPU的方向去走
TPU的share拉高
Google也直接告诉你了
它ASIC的部分可能只需要一年就回本币
它GPU还要来得更快
Google会做什么事情
很合理吗
我一定就是继续的加大采购去买更多东西
这个东西其实也是跟我们过去的几个月到半年之间
在供应链上check到的一个数据差不多
虽然我知道讲的东西可能后面
大家一定聽到我們節目就想去布局
Google的supply chain不一定會漲
好像周邊看起來只有散熱有在跑
但我們去看數據是看到
Google真的是越買越多東西
而且甚至是
就像是一年前講的東西
到現在態度都是沒有改變
其實你把全世界的這些
AI Server Supply Chain的一些特殊的零件
你如果說真的要去滿足Google的需求的話
其實全部加起來都是不夠的
就是他們所開出來的Forecast跟Defense
強到一個靠北
所以雖然可能在過去一陣子
不管是像是Google的股價
然後或是一些
Supply Chain一些零組件components
它不一定有跑得很好
只有少部分有在跑
但我們都是持續的看到
在未來展望
就是有點像Gavin Baker講的
就是你告訴我一個壞消息
你跟我講到底現在有什麼壞消息
我們看不太有壞消息
就是太恐怖了
就是他們的需求真的是開到很高
然後同時是有這些財務數字去佐證
就以前大家還會講說
你知道這些大型營業者
他們就是不停的開票出去
他們等於是一個周轉池
然後買一堆設備
這不一定會賺到錢
然後現在告訴你說
幹這些東西賺到爆炸
雖然你硬要講反方論述還是有
因為本身這個需求本身
就是他可能还是有蛮多是由
他们自己的那个循环经济去driven的
但至少我觉得现阶段我们可以这样子去看
你可以把这些模型商
视为说他们是市场里面可能扛蛮大的风险的一块
如果要更细拆的话
是模型商的这些参与应目的人
就是你去每次看到OpenAI或是Enfroppy
在哪一轮又拿到多少钱
只要这个钱持续的有进来的话
就代表他们会有源源不绝的钱
可以持续的去做投资
這時候可能就會有人問說
那到底是誰在買單
所以我們今天可以把它稍微拆開來看
晶片商或是說這些supply chain
他們出貨就收錢了
錢直接進來
所以像這些台灣人
基本上就是紮紮實的把一堆錢都賺進來
那Cloud provider呢
Google Oracle Microsoft
他們是花錢出去
然後靠五年的合約
慢慢的把錢收回來
所以他們有點像說在店前的人
但現在在其中的一些案例已經證明說
他們可以瘋狂的印鈔票
那模型商的話
他們是在燒股東的錢
去買這些算力
但是它的股東很多本身就是
上面的雲商
所以唯一一個從外面進來的錢
目前看就是這一些終端客戶
但是這個模式我們會認為說
它應該還有底氣可以持續的再跑一陣子
它應該還會再跑一陣子
最終爆掉可能還是會拉回去
像當年.com這樣
只是我覺得這個週期
可能會超出大家的想像
就是會非常的長
等到有一天你一定會發現說供需是平衡的供需平衡的那一天就會backfire所以包含說剛剛前面在電錢的這些雲他們本來是想像說再會來一段時間我就可以把錢收進來可是當今天我沒有辦法
再吸引到更新的外部資本進來
或者說在消費者這邊
大家不願意再去擴大採用
整個風向開始轉變的時候
你就會注意到模型商
他們可能就會開始出現
一些不好的財務指引
或是你會注意到
他成長率開始顯速的下滑
這時候雲商本來規劃
會收進來的這些合約的錢
就不一定收得進來
所以就會往回炸
所以這個循環融資最後就會這樣炸
可是問題是
其實這些循環融資會怎麼樣爆炸
前面已經有太多的文章
都在跟你討論說會怎麼樣爆炸
我們不是那種末日學派
就是我們知道
其實每次的股票上漲
甚至可以講一些那種老股民會講的
萬般拉台皆是為了出貨廢話
其實不是這樣子
所以每次的循環
最終也都是會有爆炸跟死掉的那一天
可是一般來說
我們不會去聚焦講
爆炸跟死掉或是掉下來
重點是有沒有辦法在上去的這一段賺到錢
而不是展現自己很聰明說
我知道這後面都會爆掉
所以我什麼都不要參與
這個經濟就是假的
一切都是虛妄
所以進入佛學的領域
所以簡單來說就是在這一次
我們去觀察在Goldman Sachs的
這場會議裡面的分享
其實是直接的跟大家展示了
Google為什麼會選擇去
加大這麼大的力度去做投資
因為答案實在是太明顯的
如果我知道我可以這樣子賺錢
我怎麼可能不會持續的去加大投資
我甚至會想要跟市場上掉更多的錢
我都要立刻的把錢丟下去
那直到怎麼樣
直到說我發現這邊的投報
它可能趨於一個中庸了
就是沒有這麼好
你可能注意到說
他開始選擇要把錢拿回去回購的時候
那可能也是一種訊號
就代表說我在這邊的投資
賺錢速度跟效率已經太低了
但不然以下的角度來說太恐怖了
我丟多少錢
我就立刻可以把多少錢賺回來
這個是真的是很難想像的東西
前面我們看到了幾個案例
可是大家還是半信半疑
覺得說搞不好是
可能伊朗他簽了一個特別好的合約
或是他供需特別緊才這樣
就連Google這種規模都告訴你說
他可以這樣賺錢
所以簡單來講還是回歸到
前幾集一概的論述
就是我們盡可能的去聚焦產業
股價就是上上下下
有時候我們也不知道說
怎麼這邊突然間噴了
或是怎麼突然間這樣崩下來
有些崩下來的東西後來又再噴上去了
所以我們盡量聚焦在產業這一塊
因為我們知道產業如果是繼續往上爬的話
這個股價就像是一條狗
也不在罵他
就是說你在遛狗啊
還有一個千神
那個是一個老生長壇他要跑上跑下可是他會順著這個產業的線去跑所以直到我們去注意到一些Early Indication然後去展示市場可能有一個反轉的訊號之前
一般我們注意到Early Indication的時候
股價可能已經崩掉蠻多了
但我們盡量還是不去當末日論者
就是會順著產業的方向去跟大家聊
這也是可能比較紮實的一個做法
所以稍微的講一下這次的事件
然後為什麼我覺得它應該算是市場裡面
超巨型的一個利多
那只是當然
目前就是一個震盪的盤子
可能就是在醞釀後面的一些力量
不曉得
但也有搞不好就是罵泡沫已經要破了
然後市場很聰明在那邊
遲遲不決定方向
只是看起來真的不太像
看起來真的不太像
因為有太多偏正向的訊號在這裡
那稍微跟大家講一下自己的一些心得
那接下來我們進入Q的部分
第一位
Jane 夢宮起嘎
我跟老公一直都是你的忠實聽眾
從一開始為了股票開始聽到
現在最喜歡你分享育兒
去年迎來可愛的女兒
女兒長得真的很像爸爸
為什麼後面要放一個哭臉的emoji
有時候還是要考慮一下爸爸的感受好不好
最近先生身體欠佳
想請夢工發揮直男巧虎的魔力
請神山Nash好好愛護自己的身體
畢竟你已經是一個孩子的爸爸了
最後祝A家人平安健康快樂
非常感謝讓我們祝Nash可以早日康復
下面一位大牛比較懶
Chika想請教您對CPU供應鏈的看法
最近研究下來我最考的是
未来CPU真正高价值
最难被取代的环节
究竟是在FAU光纤偶和元件
FAU-PIC高精度主动对位跟封装设备
还是台积电COOP本身的平台整合
或是Cohereen跟Lumonton的光引擎本身
另外这些制程究竟有多少是台积电
或客户自己掌握
多少会外包给设备或零组建厂
如果从投资角度
您认为哪个环节最有可能吃到量
而不是只有题材
这个已经是老生常谈
就是一般来讲
你進入一個新的題材
然後你就會注意到有很多的所謂的概念股
那一般我們的做法就一定是全包
就是你真的要買這個故事
你就會去把你認知的環節
像你講的高精度主動對位
那個確實是非常重要的一個環節
所以為什麼過往你看到一些那種鏡頭廠
他們本來是在做那種什麼機械加工的
然後現在機械加工
它的精度必須要搞到半導體層級
所以於是你看它直接Trade到PE30倍去
那亦或是可能一些FAU
相關的components的股票
有些甚至在市場上
大家整天在講說某某
我們就不去點名人家
那什麼他坐進去台積電
可是在台積電人家講說
根本就沒有看到這些藥廠商的東西
有什麼斬貨
可是你看他股價就永遠都在很高位的因為其實大家都會去做相對應的賭注就是他去賭這件事情會發生可是很多時候他最終你回頭看是跌破你的眼鏡的所以按照我們的經驗
就是一般我們去買題材
我們一定都是一包直接包
所以這位兄弟你拆的其實蠻完整的
就這些確實就是我們目前注意到
在整個光通supply chain裡面的價值鏈
只是你不太確定
就是裡面的價值分配最終會落在哪
也就是bottleneck到底會掉在哪個地方
哪個地方是真的可以漲價
那抑或是有些
就像說像台積電
它就是蠻多地方的一個bottleneck
可是他們就是太有品了
他們沒有像一些罵零組件
瘋狂給你漲價
因為未懂都直接講了
他們是希望跟客戶一起成長
他也很羨慕那些記憶體廠商
可以這樣去漲價
所以他不夠狠
他可能也沒有辦法再短期
就是有一些題材
或者說很高的收益進來
然後把他股價推很高
但這個推很高的蠻多
就是推一波
然後很快就掉下來
因為客戶也不是笨蛋
客戶知道說
他媽你整天在學我
他就立刻想要再去找second或是third supply chain
所以在我們的角度是你一定是先全包
你不是說每次都要買
可是就算說你每個主題
你可能就可以挑個一兩檔
然後就把錢打進去
然後總共可能佔你的部位30% 50%之類的
然後可能是分散到適當裡面
接著你一定會在過程之中
會慢慢的發現價值鏈是往哪跑
那個有時候就有點像是那種
真相越變越迷一樣
你在前面不知道
就像現在大家也會爭論
到底AI未來的價值鏈會是怎麼樣分配
是誰賺最多錢
是雲還是大模型
還是最後面發現說
其實就是這些賣產值賺最多
沒有人知道
都是邊走邊看
一般來講反正你如果方向有壓對
你一定會賺到錢
只是賺多賺少
你不一定會買到最漲的
然後你買最多
但一般來說就是整個
題材鏈的東西
如果你有包到
你應該都會是outperform大盤
所以建議你是直接光灑下去
這個沒有辦法在很初期的階段就是說
一定是哪個東西最受惠
就算它是最受惠
它也不代表在投資的角度
他是在短期內長最多的東西
因為這還是要回歸到
像前面講你漲價夠不夠狠嗎
你是不是現在大家
採購去瘋狂搶的環節
這都會有所影響
下面一位
奔雷守文泰來
艾達您好
昨天是我朋友三重女古神心神的生日
想請您用猛男的聲音
對她說出那四個字
恭喜發財
謝謝夢宮也祝您股市長紅
別再賣飛愛您
下面一位
Ry
艾達有幾個問題想問
1有想過小朋友幾歲可以罵髒話嗎
要是還沒有到會不會給他態度矯正
小時候頑童的陶肯很紅
但完全不知道意思
在玩電腦的時候唱了被我爸罵
2假如某一天不小心看到諾哈在烤箱會有什麼反應
小時候差點被抓到
最後想請用猛男的聲音助
台中Freedom黑暗殺手
盡山順利
首先第一個
我們小時候紅的是什麼
羅百吉
你後來長大才知道說
羅百吉他真的是走在超前面
DJ Jerry走在超前面
雖然可能蠻多人對他印象就是這樣
可是除此之外他的音樂
蠻多都很前衛了
你現在聽還是會認為是蠻有趣的
那時候我們去唱這些歌的時候
我們就不去點名
因為他的歌詞真的都蠻露骨的
你說我們真的想像的就是很literally
就是那個行為嗎
不是 你只是覺得很好笑很好玩
然後你的朋友都在唱
所以你就跟著唱
當然我們不會希望小朋友太早去開出口
所以你也注意到
做我孩子的時候
其實我節目的出口就越講越少
因為我一講我發現他會學我
我就會盡量去克制我自己
所以孩子也會幫助你學習
但大原則上我們會不希望他講出口
不然我也不會說我發現他模仿我
我就停下來
所以孩子也是一面禁止
告訴你說什麼是對什麼是錯
所以理論上我會希望
他在我面前都不要講出口
大概是這樣子
然後再來講說
如果注意到他開始進入一些
就是這種生理需求的解決會怎麼辦
我會假裝沒看到
如果說我知道他做的這些事情
就像說他沒有做對
或是說他做的
某些行為是有可能有風險的
我們會有那種man's talk的機會
我會提醒他
就是我希望我最終跟我的孩子
前幾天剛好聽一個投資朋友分享
他說他跟他孩子的互動就叫做沒大沒小
然後他其實覺得沒大沒小這件事不錯
因為他的目標就是成為他孩子的哥哥
而且他是用超認真的臉在講這件事情
不是說像一些那種地方阿姨說
我是我孩子的姐妹
他只是想讓自己年輕一點
沒有他是很認真把自己經營成為是哥哥
所以他會接受他的孩子有一點沒大沒小
因為沒有辦法就是你不可能通吃
你不可能期待說一個老公不會賺錢
回家什麼家事也都會做
那個一般可能是就是怪怪的
有一些事情你不知道
一般來講人的專注力是有限的
然後跟精力的投入是有限的
那個分配
你這邊好一點那邊可能就差一點
所以他如果要跟你是像朋友的互動
他就一定不會這麼尊敬你
如果說他真的超級尊敬你的話
他就是沒有辦法
跟你像是朋友沒大沒小的一個互動
所以我會希望讓孩子是
隨時可以跟我分享事情的人
所以像你跟你朋友說
我昨天尻了幾槍
這樣都沒有問題
我覺得我未來努力的方向會是這樣子
下面一位
Majaja
DibabawaMajami後面是我自己加的跟主委推薦兩個東西一 人機迷惘Pragmata主委玩過了嗎二 請問主委現在拿哪一支牌子如果有機會可以試試看Wilson Clash有機會可以試打看看
超軟Q打起來舒適又輕鬆
手肘跟手腕相對友善
順便問一下主委有遇過很有錢
但很call又很愛拗朋友的人嗎
遇到這種當生王者
真的是很堵爛
超爽的 敢愛你
這款還沒有很認真去玩它
但是我在PC跟PlayStation都已經有下載
然後稍微的小玩一點
目前還沒有時間去玩
聽說超級好玩
聽說卡普空一下onfire推的東西都很屌
然後再來講說是哪一個拍子
我一個是Welson
然後另外一個我一時間想不起來
那叫做Head
那個是朋友送我
目前就是兩隻拍子會輪流使用
然後一個拍子是屬於
你的發力要大力一點
來可以把球打回去
比較Q彈那種
然後另外一種就是很硬的
但很硬的那個我現在打起來的手感是蠻好的
那非常感謝你推薦拍子
然後再來講說有沒有遇到這樣子的人
一定會遇到
而且其實跟有錢與否沒有關係
就是蠻多人會喜歡講成說
有錢人一定就是怎麼樣
沒有啦
有錢的人有大方跟小氣的
窮鬼也有大方跟小氣的
這個人是有很多面向的
人我也不相信只有十二星座這麼少
他應該是很複雜的一種東西
所以一般跟他有錢與否沒有關係
只是他有錢又很小氣的話
會讓你格外的不爽
就是在相較之下
如果剛好又有一個
可能是比較捉襟見肘的朋友
但是他很樂於跟大家分享
你立刻就會覺得說
或者是天使前面那個是蓋你啊
不能走東西
所以一定會遇到
那一般遇到這種人
你就閃遠一點就好了
就是我自己也是不太喜歡
就是很愛算啊
然後或者是過於精明
就他最聰明別人都是笨蛋那種
我是不喜歡這樣子的人啊
所以就直接閃開就好
下面一位
Fan Fanny
猛攻大大您好
我男友是從麥克風裝帆就開始聽的聽眾
您的節目是他每天通勤南侃內湖的陪伴
那只要同一集重複播放兩次
還沒有到內湖他就會抓狂
我很感謝有您線上陪伴辛苦通勤的他
想借您的親口用川普的聲音祝他9月22號生日快樂
再用柔弱小貓的聲音說
柔弱小貓是他媽殺小
上班辛苦了
之前看到小朋友
我想把我自己殺掉
之前看到小朋友滑雪好可愛
想請問夢公會想帶兩位小朋友去滑雪嗎
推薦您新野度假村
裡面還有很多設施可以玩個幾天都沒有問題
最後我的水豚男友非常喜歡橘子
請問可以用橘子當這一集的標題嗎
那最後祝您績效長紅全家平安順心
之前是有稍微研究一下滑雪
因為有一陣子我注意到身邊有蠻多朋友就整天都跑去滑雪我也不知道到底在滑什麼意思因為你問他們他們都說很好玩然後下面一句就說要小心摔斷手注意掉下去的時候骨盆可能會裂掉
我說那到底好玩在哪
就是為什麼要去做這種事情
所以一開始看大家在滑雪的時候
當然有想過說是不是要去
所以那時候就在找
然後後來發現說我可能找錯
因為我就發現說
身邊有些朋友會跑去二世骨
然後後來找二世骨就是一個
反正就是很資本主義點到最滿的地方
你願意花錢可能也會好玩
但不一定
就是有時候你還是要去找一些在地的東西
可能會更多有趣的
所以確實有人跟我推薦
星野
而且星野是不是類似那種全包式的
我非常忘記了
就有人也跟我推了幾個全包式的
就是小朋友可以有所照顧
那你也可以玩到的
或許之後會找機會去試看看
但我後來就是聽了太多滑雪的恐怖故事
然後後來有一個朋友跟我分享
他有一個朋友跑去滑雪
然後接著就跌倒
然後跌倒的時候
大家不知道他跌倒
因為他就坐在旁邊
大家有在休息什麼的
然後後來還知道說原來他是跌倒
然後在那邊已經放空了
然後接著過去幾天的滑雪的故事
他全部都忘記了
他全部都忘光了
他根本就不知道
他為什麼在這個地方之類的
所以想到很恐怖
然後外加也看到有滿多朋友
就是摔斷手
或者說什麼屁股撞傷之類的
我覺得我會三思啦
可能會挑那種最簡單的東西
小玩一下就好
然後因為現在生命對我來講
是一個滿重要的事情
那下面一位
James Chung
夢宮午安
希望夢宮用下面的心境說出
PN好痛四個字
1. 持骨擋天全面漲停
PN好痛
二川普拿出小版本後跌停三天
PM好痛
三生氣
四期待
PM好痛
五害羞
最後祝您全家平安天天開心
你們不要再叫我去模仿一些聲音了
因為我有點像說求來就打
可是有些東西就是我講完之後
我會發自內心的憎恨自己
就是不要再做這種事了
下面我也講
MK想問你美股當初怎麼開槓桿的融資好貴
對美股就是融資特別貴的一個地方
如果你今天是用option的話
你去把它換算成為利率
也是很貴的一個東西
但好處就是什麼
就如果說你真的不小心尻對的話
就蠻爽的
我最近一次尻option就是
前面有一波Intel
那個真的是極爽
但基本上option它有點類似說
可能蠻多最後都會是賠錢
或是說小賠收藏這樣
偶爾撈到一個大的
然後大的去補全部
我是怎麼樣使用槓桿
一般會使用option
然後再外加一些margin
你就不要去想那個利率
你去開融資槓桿
你就是想說
我就是要賺的比較多
就是這樣
當然你在台灣開會是更自在的一件事情
台灣的成本大概落到2-3%
現在應該全面都上修到3%左右了美股的話10幾%有時候都是蠻常見的一個事情所以就是要去評估一下自己過往的績效是怎麼樣然後再考慮要不要來開槓桿那一般開槓桿
它不會是長期的擺演後
都比較偏向是去trade的一些看法
或是消息
或是這樣子做
那下面一位
三個愛心
孟公安我有幾個問題想問
不方便的話直接跳過
依孝南不公開的遊戲
個人猜測是
對就是蠻會猜的
但我們不能夠跟大家講
個人很愛隔壁太太二黑白妹
之前你說你是黃油專家
有沒有你很愛的小黃油
隔壁太太二真的是一個
把文本做到極限的小黃油
特別是在你玩完之後的後日談
他會從太太的角度
去講自己貝德行為
那個文本是非常強大的一個黃油
再來因為後來我意識到
就是有時候我太自我了
節目本來我的態度就是
我想分享什麼就分享什麼
但有時候我會意識到
我們這個是有那種合家收聽的
有些家長可能會比較難以去跟小朋友去解釋說
到底現在發生什麼事情
所以有些東西我可能會講
有些東西我可能就後來我自己會去做一點調整
還是盡可能的口污遮攔
想家怎麼講什麼
因為那也是原汁原味
但去推薦黃油這個
你來問我
那我就可以回你
但你要我去推
我可能就比較不方便
三 夢公你有沒有考慮養貓
貓真的好可愛
而且不需要六
大小便清潔方便
沒有養過的人可能覺得貓面很冷漠
但其實家貓也是很親人的
最後祝您全家健康快樂
一切平安愛您
這個貓咪的話我自己是有養過
而且我至今對那隻貓咪
都有很大的一個虧欠
簡單講這個貓咪
是我們那時候在台東去做飛行訓練的時候
然後有一次我們去台東大學的健身房
然後在門口的一個
反正往健身房的路上
它有一個大牌
然後這個大牌上面就是有很簡單的水泥
可以通過這樣
然後在大牌裡面
我們就聽到有貓咪的喵喵喵喵的聲音
這一個很早期的節目
說不定有分享過
總之大家就把這隻貓咪帶回家
然後一起養在宿舍裡面
然後後來大家都知道這個故事就是
微航倒閉
然後我們的公司就直接就地解散
當時大家就先回家
雖然我們家同事
所有都還是有在線上拘飛
可是當時真的沒有人知道說
未來會發生什麼事情
所以大家都是一個非常難過的心態
然後那隻貓咪就有點變成說
不知道誰要帶回家
那我就是屬於那一種
也不是說我正義趕快撒小
我想說好反正就感覺我應該可以
我就把它選擇先帶回家去養
但是後來的事情就發生得太快
就是接著在台北搞東西
然後後來又遇到我老婆什麼結婚
小孩之類的
然後後來我們有一隻狗狗丘口
有丘口之後
這個貓咪就沒有辦法跟狗在同一個環境裡面
〔此段辨識失敗，約 40:00 起〕